[Música]
vamos a cambiar de tema La Inteligencia
artificial es un avance casi milagroso
pero creado por el hombre para mejorar
la calidad de vida del hombre sin
embargo visto los avances que son más
rápidos de lo que podríamos incluso
registrar ahí cada vez más suspenso
sobre las afectaciones negativas en los
oficios que desempeñamos Y si seríamos
reemplazados por un algoritmo o por una
máquina para conversar sobre este tema
se conecta con directo América y doy a
Salazar ella es fundadora y presidenta
del observatorio del impacto social y
ético de la Inteligencia artificial
Odisea Muchísimas gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros
Muchísimas gracias a vosotros un placer
estar aquí comienzo preguntándole por
las acciones que están tomando Ya varias
empresas que han anunciado que
invertirán en Inteligencia artificial
para llevar a cabo ciertas tareas Amazon
no ya lo hizo actualizando sus sistemas
de entrega IBM por ejemplo buscará
sustituir a 8.000 de sus trabajadores
por herramientas de Inteligencia
artificial y dijo que va a tratar de
hacerlo en el menor corto plazo posible
estas noticias llegan al tiempo que las
grandes tecnologías siguen efectuando
despidos masivos de personal
Cuál será la tendencia Aunque al parecer
se ve muy clara
sí lo primero que debemos hacer lo que
pienso yo que debemos hacer es realmente
ver a la Inteligencia artificial como
una herramienta que debemos usar en la
actualidad no es que las empresas
quieran sustituir determinados puestos
de trabajo por Inteligencia artificial
sino que es casi un deber pensar que
tenemos ante nosotros pues una
herramienta capaz de gestionar distintos
procesos con mucha mayor rapidez que los
seres humanos automatizar Muchas tareas
y sin duda los empresarios no serían
buenos empresarios sino buscarán estos
sistemas de Inteligencia artificial
Entonces es esta es un deber para las
empresas y las organizaciones usar esta
herramienta pero quería poner un símil
para que lo comprendiera las personas
que nos están viendo un poco mejor no lo
veo muy diferente que lo que ocurrió con
internet Con el impacto de internet o
con la Revolución Industrial realmente
las empresas tenían El Deber de usar
esas máquinas para mejorar y eso no
tiene por qué significar algo negativo
para la población sin duda Pues es lo un
proceso normal un proceso lógico una
nueva impacto de una tecnología que va a
cambiar nuestra rutina laboral y desde
quizá desde el punto de vista del
trabajador lo que tenemos que tomar es
una actitud un poco más de adaptación
ante estas nuevas rutinas que va a
imponer la Inteligencia artificial Bueno
desde ese punto de vista el New York
Times ha asegurado en algunos de sus
artículos que la Inteligencia artificial
podría acabar con lo que llamamos los
trabajos aburridos que se realizan
normalmente hablemos un poco sobre este
tema Si le parece sí Perfecto es justo
esta la cuestión la Inteligencia
artificial pues lo que hace es hacer muy
bien esta serie de trabajos repetitivos
que quizá para el ser humano es llegan a
ser incluso aburridos yo no lo vería
como como una sustitución de un trabajo
en sí mismo sino la sustitución de
determinadas tareas dentro de ese puesto
de trabajo Por ejemplo yo diría hacer
informes específicos hacer análisis
masivos de
determinadas cuentas que puede suponer
una tarea muy mecánica para muchos
trabajadores dejando al empleado en Sí
al ser humano pues otras tareas que
aportan más calidad en sobre esto hay
que ver la Inteligencia artificial como
una herramienta de ayuda al ser humano
tal y como quizá nos podemos ayudar de
en los trabajos físicos de un tractor
para arar más Campos que en la
antigüedad pues hoy en día vamos a usar
estas herramientas de Inteligencia
artificial para aumentar no entra
nuestra capacidad cognitiva y llegar a
hacer mucho más de lo que somos capaces
de hacer sin ella imaginemos lo que
hubiéramos sido capaces de hacer si no
hubiéramos inventado la calculadora o
los ordenadores realmente el cómputo que
hubiéramos podido hacer con nuestro
cerebro hubiera sido mucho menor hoy en
día gracias a la Inteligencia artificial
a estos modelos de idea generativa como
chat gpt pues vamos a poder realmente
multiplicar de manera exponencial las
acciones que a las que podemos llegar
Los seres humanos sin duda Es una
herramienta que que Útil para la
humanidad y pero es un también un reto
un reto tremendo para todos nosotros que
tenemos que adaptarnos de manera muy
rápida estos cambios y yo Ahí es donde
veo el problema en que como sociedad es
todo esto se nos está viniendo encima de
una manera pues muy rápida y es un reto
para el ser humano pues poder pues poder
ir con ese reto ir adaptándonos para
para poder no quedarnos sin puesto de
trabajo pero veo más que sí que Perdone
que le interrumpa lo que pasa es que
evidentemente la tecnología y además con
buenos propósitos siempre es una buena
noticia sin embargo el problema le diría
yo tiene que ver más con la desigualdad
en la que llega esta esta tecnología a
las personas y en ese sentido como ya se
nos está acabando el tiempo quisiera
preguntarle en su opinión qué
profesiones tienden a fortalecerse
gracias a la inteligencia Y qué
profesiones podrían eventualmente tender
a desaparecer o a disminuirse mucho y le
pongo un ejemplo conmigo misma en China
Ya se está probando una presentadora
digital que realiza bastantes tareas y
de manera muy eficiente además
Sí yo creo que más que un trabajo se
tienden a desaparecer las tareas más
mecánicas pero sin duda también hay en
muchos puestos de trabajo de alta
cualificación que pueden desaparecer yo
más que una que una profesión en sí
misma desaparecerán determinadas tareas
como comentaba antes y lo que y lo que y
lo que diría a todos los usuarios es que
vuelvo a incidir en esta capacidad de
adaptación cualquier trabajo que
tengamos está en peligro hoy en día si
no nos adaptamos cualquiera desde tema
desde empleo relacionados con altos
directivos a la medicina a cualquier
tarea relacionada con bueno con trabajo
de oficina y serán aquellos incluso los
trabajos que llegan a ser creativos lo
que debemos de hacer es aprender a
usarla a todos los niveles Yo creo que
es algo que cualquiera y más ahora con
estos modelos de idea generativa podemos
aprender porque es bastante fácil es una
interacción con una máquina que es capaz
de hablar en el lenguaje que hablamos
los humanos y la clave está ahí
cualquier profesión está en riesgo y lo
que debemos hacer es adaptarnos bueno
Pues será un proceso que nos tomará años
y que esperemos termine de buena manera
muchísimas gracias y doy a Salazar o
fundadora de odiseia que tenga un feliz
día Muchas gracias quédense con nosotros
todos nuestros televidentes Porque nos
falta todavía más camino en este directo
América ya volvemos
[Música]